Candid Truth
What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. Have you seen
that the news has been talking about
asteroids and meteorites and it's over
and over and over and we've been seeing
this for the past couple of years and
I'm like, "Wow, is there a reason that
we're getting more meteorites and
asteroids now than ever before?" I
actually looked that question up and
Google said, "Oh, that's not true. You
know, billions of years ago asteroids
hit the earth a ton of times, you know?"
And the only reason that we're seeing it
more now is because well, there's more
cameras and dash cams and ring cams and
all this stuff.
That may or may not be true, but I I
think that we are seeing something a
little different. I don't think we're
seeing rocks falling from the skies. I
think there's a great deception. We know
biblically that in the end times there's
going to be a grand illusion, a grand
deception. Satan is setting up his final
masquerade and right now he is bringing
the world into utter chaos so that he
can bring in the order, the new world
order so that he can come as the cosmic
savior and save the day when everyone
reaches rock bottom and they feel like
they're hopeless in everything. He's
going to come upon the scene as Christ
and millions of people are going to be
deceived because they're not studying
the Bible and they're not studying
prophecy. They don't understand so many
things that are going on in the world
and they don't understand that there's
going to be a deception first before
Christ comes. That Christ is not going
to set foot on the earth, but we're
going to meet him in the air.
He said, "If they say he's in the secret
chambers, do not go. If they say he's in
the desert, don't even look at it
because the deception is going to be so
great. It's a grand illusion that's
going to deceive millions."
Check this out. We're going to look at
these meteors and we're going to look at
some strange stuff about these meteors,
right? Here in the US tonight and to
this incredible sight seen in several
states, a 7-ton meteor shooting across
the sky. The sonic boom heard over
multiple states. The meteor 6 ft in
diameter, the ground shaking. Here's
Briana and Ali tonight.
Tonight, NASA says this bright red
fireball streaking through the sky
moving at 40,000 mph and seen from at
least 10 states is a rare daylight
meteor crashing into earth.
>> OH, WHAT THE
WAS THAT?
THE asteroid bursting through the
earth's atmosphere sending loud sonic
booms rattling homes from Ohio to
Kentucky.
The blast so powerful it shook the
ground. The rumbling registering on a
seismograph.
>> It it was JUST LIKE A BOOM, LIKE THAT.
THE meteor seen just before 9:00 a.m.
for barely 5 seconds traveling more than
34 miles in the upper atmosphere before
breaking apart above Medina, Ohio and
seen across the northeast.
>> Anybody see or hear what blew up?
Definitely too big for fireworks. We
felt a shockwave. We're not sure what it
is, but it was big. NASA says the meteor
nearly 6 ft in diameter weighing roughly
7 tons lit up the sky. It was even
spotted by a NOAA satellite in space
unleashing the same amount of energy as
250 tons of TNT. This thing just broke
apart violently, scattered fragments
everywhere and this explosion generated
a shockwave or a pressure wave that
traveled to the ground and that's the
explosions people saw.
So, this is what I think is interesting
is that they're saying that this meteor
that this fireball going across the sky
made an explosion
that shook the earth.
Made a shockwave happen. I know people
are going to think, "Oh, you're just
ignorant. You don't understand how
things work. You're not a scientist and
all this stuff." A rock flying through
the sky on fire blew up, exploded
causing a shockwave on earth, all right?
That doesn't seem like a natural
phenomenon in any kind of way.
I've never felt this in my entire life.
I've never read a historical
documentation of a meteor or an asteroid
that flew in from outer space, exploded
and caused a shockwave that was felt by,
you know, states all around.
That's a little suspicious to me. We're
going to look at some more fishy things
that are going on.
But here's another news clip and I just
think this is kind of interesting about
this guy who's got these magnets and
he's like, "Man, if I could just find a
meteorite, it'd be like make my whole
lifetime." This belt here it's got
magnets in it, rare earth magnets and
you can use this to authenticate if it's
actually uh a meteorite. Why the
fascination?
It's just uh
something coming from space, you know.
Steven Sladek also drove to the park
from Cleveland carrying a stick with a
magnet on it. He considers himself a
rock hound and the chance to find
meteorites is like a dream come true. If
I could find a piece, it'd be like just
amazing for me, you know.
A piece of space history. Yeah.
>> You're on a quest. Yeah, definitely.
Meanwhile, December Harris says her
cousin did find an unusual rock and
picked it up with a tissue on their
Medina driveway. What are the chances?
Yeah. But you know, it's going to be the
same thing for anybody. What would be
the chances?
>> The dark burnt-looking rock is not a
confirmed meteorite, but December feels
like it's from out of this world. An
inch long, I would say. Has all these
strikes in it. Hard as can be.
It definitely looks like something that
definitely is not around here. Imagine
that, a rock that's hard as can be.
This is This is crazy. I mean, we're
talking about a rock here. This guy's
like, "If I could find this rock, it
would just be amazing."
I get it, you know, people believe that
there's this ever-expanding universe and
there's things shooting around and if
something fell into our atmosphere, it'd
be a great find, right? If you actually
found that. The question is, why is
nobody finding anything?
This thing was huge. It blew up. It
supposedly hit the earth somewhere.
Nobody can find it.
All right.
I got questions. I got questions. A rock
entered into our atmosphere, blew up,
caused a shockwave. Nobody can find a
particle anywhere.
I got questions. I think we should all
be questioning mainstream media news. I
don't trust the news. I don't trust
politics. It's all a big show. We are
living on a stage. The world is a stage
and Satan is the puppet master, okay?
You have to stop believing everything
you see and hear on TV. Satan is
bringing this whole thing down.
With the Epstein files coming out, you
you can't trust anyone anymore, right?
With UFOs are about to be disclosed by
Trump. We're being told by the military
that we talked to non-human
intelligences. Now there's asteroids
coming. There's things from all over,
every angle something is coming at us,
right? We're going to World War right
now. They're saying that this is going
to be Armageddon. It's going to bring
Jesus back. That's what they're saying
in the government. This is insane. 2026
is the craziest year ever. So far.
Buckle your seat belts. I wanted to show
you guys something about asteroids and
meteorites. This is what they say, this
is what they tell us are holes in the
ground from meteors and asteroids and
these things are like miles wide.
They're super deep. They got these
upturned edges. Looks like something
smashed into the ground. Um I have a
certain question though. I have a really
interesting question.
Where's the rock?
Where is it? Where the rock go? A giant
rock miles in diameter
smashed into the ground and there's not
a trace of it.
And of course, NASA is going to tell us
2 billion years ago
uh something that's 155 to 186 miles
wide smashed into earth causing a crater
and NASA, we can trust NASA, right? 2
billion years ago. Are we going to trust
these people? These are the same people
whose acronym just happens to mean by
coincidence the Hebrew word for to lead
astray, to delude, to seduce, beguile
and deceive. Are these the people that
we're going to put our trust in? All
these holes around the world
and we can't find one rock. Not one.
Where the rock go?
Even if it smashed and broke in half or
broke into a million pieces
it's going to be somewhere.
This is This never happens in nature.
You don't have a car wreck and the the
car just disappears. So, this made me
think about Dr. Carol Rosin. If you
don't If you're not familiar with her,
she was the spokesperson for Wernher von
Braun who is a NASA rocket scientist. He
was one of the forming members of NASA.
He was a Nazi scientist who helped form
NASA. If that tells you anything.
And in his dying years, I believe he
started to have a guilty conscience and
he started admitting some things to Dr.
Carol Rosin. Now, just to tell you, this
lady's not a conspiracy theorist. She's
not a I don't know that she's a
self-professed Christian or anything
like that. She actually
um is on the board of the Disclosure
Project because she wants to see aliens
come. I don't know how after she had
this conversation with Wernher von
Braun,
but what I'm getting at is she has
no agenda except to tell what really
happened.
This is what Wernher von Braun told her.
I met the late Dr. Wernher von Braun in
early '74.
Von Braun's purpose in life during the
last years of his life, his dying years,
was to educate the public and decision
makers about why space-based weapons are
a dumb, dangerous, destabilizing, too
costly, unnecessary, unworkable,
undesirable idea.
The strategy that Wernher von Braun
taught me was that first the [music]
Russians are going to be considered to
be the enemy. In fact, when I met him in
'74, they were the enemy, the identified
[music]
enemy. We were told that they had killer
satellites. We were told that they were
coming to get us and control us, the
dirty commies, that whole story.
>> [music]
>> First, the Russians were the enemy
against whom we're going to build
space-based weapons. Then terrorists
would be identified, [music]
and that was soon to follow. We heard a
lot about terrorism.
Then we were going to identify third
world country crazies. We now call them
nations of concern. But he said [music]
that would be the third enemy against
whom we would be needing to build
space-based weapons.
And the next enemy was asteroids. Now,
at this point, he kind of chuckled the
first time he said it.
Asteroids, against asteroids we're going
to build space-based weapons. So, it was
funny then.
And the funniest one of all was against
what he called aliens,
extraterrestrials. [music]
That would be the final card.
And over and over and over during the
four years that I knew him and was
giving his speeches for him,
he would bring up that last card and
remember, Carol, the last card is the
alien card. We're going to have to build
space-based weapons [music] against
aliens, and all of it, he said, is a
lie.
I remember when I was really into aliens
and I just wanted all the information to
come out, I saw her on the board of that
Disclosure Project.
But did you hear what she said? She said
Wernher von Braun said that the
deception to bring about the New World
Order is going to be terrorist,
asteroids,
and then aliens, the final card. Now, is
it just a coincidence that she was
hearing this in 1974? Here it is 2026,
and we've been hearing a ton about
asteroids. I wish I had a clip, a
collage clip of all the times that
they've said, "Oh, this month an
asteroid will come so close to Earth. It
might hit us. It might destroy
humanity." And they I mean, it's so
ridiculous they start saying like, "It's
the size of 10,000 flamingos." I'm not
even joking. Like, this is what they
say. They use these very comical uh
measurements to tell you how big this
thing is instead of saying like a school
bus or you know, a football field or
something like that. It's ridiculous.
They're laughing in our faces because
they know it's all a lie. Actually, the
news reporters are just puppets. It's
all a script to them. This is crazy. If
you still believe this stuff by the end
of this, I don't know what to think. But
that clip was from the documentary
called Disclosed that I made for Little
Light Studios. Go check out Little Light
Studios. Look up Disclosed. It's a
35-minute documentary. It's short,
shareable. It'll tell you everything you
need to know about this final deception.
It's well produced, and it's not like a
live long live like this. You can share
this with all your family and friends.
If a meteor really caused that hole, we
would see a giant rock stuffed down in
there.
For one, the top side that you're seeing
right there,
it it didn't even have an impact. It
didn't It didn't hit the ground or
anything. So, why would it disappear?
How would something
as big as miles wide completely vanish?
Not just from one site, not from two
sites, but every site on Earth. I I hope
this is getting the wheels turning
because these craters are not from
meteors, and they're not from
asteroids. We just saw on the videos
from the news that these things were
flying horizontal, they were flying 45°,
but every crater on Earth
is like a a pond, like a pool. It's not
There's no skid marks. There's no
sideways pit. There's no large rocks in
the bottom from the actual meteor
breaking apart.
All it is is a hole on the ground, and
we are supposed to believe that this is
a meteor that's 155 miles wide. I'm not
buying it, guys. This right here is a
geyser. This is what a geyser looks
like.
And here's what it looks like when it
blows up. And why am I showing you a
picture of a geyser that is much smaller
than 155
miles wide?
Because of something that happened in
the Bible days.
This is what a geyser looks like
underground. But what did the Bible say
in Genesis 7:11? In the 600th year of
Noah's life, in the second month, the
17th day of the month, the same day were
all the fountains of the great deep
broken up, and the windows of heaven
were opened. This is describing Noah's
flood. How did the whole world get
flooded?
With just a little rain from the clouds?
No, the heavens literally opened up
and water gushed down. There was
fountains of the great deep that busted
open and shot up into the air.
And you can see some like animated
illustrations of this from
Answers in Genesis and even in the Noah
movie, and I know they're just
illustrations, but that's what it looked
like. A giant opening, the water busted
out of there, and that's what we're
seeing. Evidence of the flood. So, why
would NASA say, "Oh, it was actually
from a large rock that entered our world
billions of years ago" because it hides
God. It hides the truth of the Bible. It
hides the flood, and you look at it, and
it's ridiculous that we even believe it.
That we even believe this giant hole
came from a huge rock that doesn't exist
and it doesn't ever enter in at a 45°
angle.
It's insane what we believe because the
people in white lab coats told us and
because we saw an illustration in a
science textbook.
Look, you guys might believe scientists,
but they're the same ones that are
telling you that this universe came from
a big bang of nothingness exploded and
shrapnel's flying around in
ever-expanding universe, and and you're
an
a one-celled single-celled amoeba that
crawled up on the land, turned into a
monkey, and became a man. That's in the
science textbooks. Billions of years,
which defies science on every level.
We can use science to prove that this
world is a young Earth.
And these are the people that we're
believing. The same people say, "Trust
the science. This This shot is 100%
safe, 100% effective. Just sign this
waiver." And now people are dropping
dead. These are the people we're
trusting, all right?
Now, here's another verse
talking about the same flood, and it
says, "The fountains also of the deep
and the windows of heaven were stopped,
and the rain from heaven were
restrained." This is talking about when
the flood finally stopped.
So, for 40 days,
the windows of heaven were opened, and
water was gushing out from somewhere on
Earth. Wouldn't there be some kind of
remnants left of holes that were gushing
water out of the Earth? Absolutely.
And instead of seeing that proof and
saying, "Wow, this is proof of Noah's
flood and the Bible is true,"
NASA,
Hebrew word for deceive and beguile and
lead astray, says, "No, no, no.
That's a giant rock that fell from the
sky. It You can't see it, but that's
what happened. Trust us. We're
scientists."
I'm not buying it, guys. Wernher von
Braun, we were just talking about him.
He had an interesting tombstone. Like I
said, I believe in his last days he
started to have a guilty conscience, and
he started to share some things. He
talked about the asteroid lie. He talked
about the alien card lie so that they
could build space-based weapons. That's
what the lie is all about, building
weapons pointed towards the heavens. And
look what he has on his tombstone.
This is
a Bible verse, Psalms 19:1.
Let's read it.
To the chief musician, a psalm of David.
The heavens declare the glory of God,
and the firmament showeth his handywork.
Why would a NASA scientist
put this on his tombstone?
That the firmament shows God's
handywork.
Well, what is the firmament? We don't
hear this word used, but let's look to
the original Hebrew.
And let's look at Genesis 6 where it
says Genesis 1:6 where it says, "And God
said, 'Let there be a firmament in the
midst of the waters, and let it divide
the waters from the waters.' And God
made the firmament and divided the
waters which were under the firmament
from the waters which were above the
firmament." What does that mean? Waters
above the firmament?
And it was so.
And God called the firmament heaven, and
the evening and the morning were the
second day.
Now, some people will say the firmament
is the ozone layer, the atmosphere. Some
people will say the waters above are the
clouds.
Some people will say, "No, the
firmament, that's that's a
mistranslation. It's actually the
expanse. It's It's space expanding and
and going." Well, explain to me, what
are the waters above
the firmament then? What are the waters
that are above outer space?
Because they're They got probes and
satellites, and they can't find water
anywhere. Please explain to me what it
means when it says the firmament
separates the waters below from the
waters above the firmament. Well, let's
look to the
uh original Hebrew. It says that this
word firmament means to spread out, to
beat, to stamp, to stretch. Then it says
to pound the earth, to expand, to
overlay. Here's more. It says the Hebrew
verb raqa
primarily means to spread out or to beat
out. It is often used in the context of
creating something by hammering or
spreading, such as metalwork or the
expanse of the heavens.
The term conveys the idea of expansion
and formation through a deliberate or
forceful action.
Then we continue and it says, "In
ancient Near Eastern cultures,
metalworking was a significant craft,
and the process of hammering metal into
thin sheets was a common practice. This
imagery is reflected in the use of raqa
to describe the creation of the
firmament in Genesis, where God spreads
out the heavens like a canopy."
The concept of raqa also aligns with the
ancient understanding of the sky as a
solid dome or expanse. This is not my
conspiracy theory words, okay? This is
literally the Hebrew for what the word
firmament means.
This is what Wernher von Braun put on
his tombstone. I think this rocket
scientist actually knew something. He
knew that rockets don't go anywhere,
that all of them arch outward. I'm going
to have to show you an illustration of
this because they launch these rockets,
they never go straight up,
they always go out here somewhere
and go out into the ocean somewhere.
Some people believe that these rockets
are actually going out into the Bermuda
Triangle, and that's why if anyone tries
to go that direction, they disappear
because this secret cannot be found out.
This is Satan's final masquerade. His
final opus is to appear as a visitant
from a far distant galaxy, a cosmic
Christ.
He's going to deceive the entire world
by
pretending to be a
an alien.
An alien that can do lying signs and
wonders, that can heal people, that can
bring peace upon Earth,
that can get rid of all disease, all
climate change, and he's going to be an
angel of light, and the whole world is
going to wonder after him and be
deceived by him by means of these
miracles, Revelation says. So, as I
stated, these are not my words. These
are the words of the Hebrew.
And so, when you look at Amos 9:6, it
says, "The one who builds his upper
chambers in the heavens and his and has
founded his vaulted dome over the earth,
he who calls for the waters of the sea
and pours them out on the face of the
earth, the Lord is his name."
So, Amos says that the heavens that are
stretched out like a tent, and we're all
grasshoppers inside, and it says it's a
vaulted dome, a firmament that's beaten
out with a hammer.
This is how the Bible describes our
Earth. But again, the the NASA
corporation, the word that means to de-
deceive, beguile,
lead astray, has taught us something
completely different, that you're an
insignificant speck flying around in an
ever-expanding universe, and there's
rocks that are flying into our universe,
flying into our atmosphere, and causing
big explosions. This is all a deception,
guys. Look, if you type
Hebrew Earth on Google,
this is what you're going to find.
I didn't say anything I didn't say any
kind of shape. I just simply typed
Hebrew Earth. If you type Biblical
Earth, this is what you're going to
find.
You can do this yourself. It doesn't
matter if you're signed in, it doesn't
matter if you're incognito, you're going
to find the same thing.
And it's all because they want to build
this space force. Why do they want to
build space force? They have to have a
legitimate reason to build weapons
pointed towards the heavens. Why?
Because Christ is returning soon. And if
you understand prophecy and you read the
Bible, you're going to see in Revelation
16:13-14
that three unclean spirits like frogs,
they are the spirits of devils working
miracles, which go forth unto the kings
of the earth and of the whole world to
gather them to the battle of the great
day of God Almighty. These
interdimensional beings that the
military is literally telling us they
talk to and communicate with at US
congressional hearings are these frogs
that Revelation talks about, the spirits
of devils that are going to the kings of
the earth, the militaries of the world,
and gathering them together.
Reagan said, "If we were threatened by
some alien threat, we'd all come
together." And what's happening?
UFOs, asteroids, fearful signs in the
heavens, the Bible says.
This is how Satan
is uniting the world into a battle
against the second coming of Christ. And
if we are not grounded in the word of
God, we are going to fall for this
deception, and we are going to side with
demons in a battle against Christ.
Because what I believe is going to to
happen soon
is Satan is going to appear
as a cosmic savior,
and he's going to say, "Look,
I can fix all your problems." And he's
going to be doing lying signs and
wonders. He's going to be doing
miracle-working demons, the Bible says.
He's going to get rid of all the
problems that we have, and he's going to
bring peace and safety.
And then he's going to say, "You know
what? I've come to help you guys because
there's an evil alien invader coming to
Earth, and if you don't side with us,
you're never going to survive. But we've
come to help you in this battle."
And humanity will be siding with demonic
spirits in a battle against Jesus
Christ.
I pray that you guys start questioning
some things. I got some serious
questions. I want you to watch this
video. It's only 26 minutes long, and it
proves beyond a shadow of a doubt that
these people are liars, that space is
not what you think it is, that these
people are faking everything. I compare
NASA
NASA footage to NASA footage, ISS
footage to ISS footage. There's no
consistency. You can see they're using
green screens and VR and all kinds of
stuff. They are faking everything.
And yet we're eating it up. And like
that guy said, "If I could just find one
rock, it would just be amazing." I hope
you guys enjoy this video. I hope it was
eye-opening. I hope it makes you think.
Start questioning everything, even the
rocks falling from the sky that there's
no evidence of. And check it out,
there's actually evidence of the sulfur
balls that destroyed Sodom and Gomorrah.
The only incidents that we have in the
Bible of anything falling from the sky
was fireballs from God out of heaven.
They were sulfur balls, and you can
still find them today. They still set on
fire. They're actually there, unlike
these gigantic meteors that cause these
holes.
They're not anywhere to be found. And
yet we're believing that, and we're not
believing the Bible. Blows my mind. It's
crazy. The deception is here. If you
like this video, please give it a thumbs
up. Really helps this video getting it
out into the algorithm. Please share
this with your family and friends
because we are living in the end times,
a time of great deception. If you would
like to support this ministry, you can
do so by going to candidtruth.org. We
got Cash App, Venmo, Zelle, PayPal. We
even have Patreon. We got a lot of cool
t-shirts and hoodies and mugs and all
that, and we get about $5 per sale from
there, and it really helps this ministry
to stay alive. If you have been donating
to this ministry, we cannot thank you
enough. We love you. We thank you. We
try to get back to every one of you, but
some of these platforms like Zelle and
Cash App won't even let us respond. But
we see you, and we love you, and we
cannot do this without you, and we will
see you next time on Candid Truth.